المترجم: Fatima El Kerchaoui
المدقّق: Riyad Almubarak
هو صانع التغيير
مؤيد محسن
عمري عشرين سنة عندما ذهبت إلى الحرب.
لماذا؟
وضاع العمر،
وبعد فترة طويلة عدت إلى الحياة المدنية.
تركت الرسم عندما انضممت للجيش طبعا،
ولكن عندما عدت قلت لنفسي: "لابد أن أرسم!"
وللأسف وجدت رسم عراقي بدون هوية،
وإن كان فيه شيء بسيط من الهوية،
فهي هوية متلاشية.
وللأسف كل الزملاء يشتغلون
وفق مفهوم "الأبستراكت"
ومتأثرين بالمدارس الغربية.
حسنا، السؤال الآن هو:
لماذا أتأثر بالغرب؟
لماذا لا أنطلق من ذاتي؟
سقراط رحمه الله يقول: "اعرف نفسك بنفسك".
الهوية يا إخوتي تعني حضورك كطاقة،
كذات فاعلة،
تتحدث عن الزمان والمكان والبيئة
التي ولدت وترعرت فيها.
مضافا إلى ذلك نسق المعايير والمعارف
التي تعلمتها من الحياة
والتي تأثرت بها من الخارج ومن الداخل.
الهوية تقوم بالاستعارة
والاستعارة تبنى على الشكل والتقنية
والمضمون، المعنى.
مثال:
لوحة موت سقراط.
لوحة رائعة رسمها الفرنسي العظيم دافيد.
رسمها قبل عامين من اندلاع الثورة الفرنسية
وبهذا استعار أشكال ومعنى
من التراث الإغريقي.
وضع سقراط في منتصف اللوحة
يمد يده إلى كأس السم لكي يتناوله،
يشير بذلك إلى احترام القانون.
أراد دافيد طبعا أن يوضح معنى الديمقراطية
إلى بعض السياسيين المتزمتين
في فرنسا آنذاك.
ومثال آخر:
جيروم.
استعار جيروم من الشرق الشكل الزخرفي
والسحر المعماري
وقدم بالتالي جمال إلى الإنسانية.
لديه هوية ولكن باستعارات شرقية،
استعارات من الخارج.
أنا كمؤيد محسن
قررت أن تكون استعارتي من الداخل.
الموضوع متعب جدا طبعا
وليس من السهل أن تجد شكلا
يميز أعمالك.
لذلك رجعت إلى تاريخ الرافدين القديم
وبحثت في التاريخ وبدأت أحفر باللغة الأثرية
وأنقب عن المعنى والشكل
وحققت شيئًا بسيطًا متواضعًا.
من وجهة نظر النقاد هناك هوية،
هوية رصينة بالخطاب.
أخدت مسلة حمراء مع شظاياها
ووضعتها على عربة خشب
والعربة يقودها فرد عراقي مغيب الرأس،
مغيب الفكر ومصادر.
يجب لنا أن نتكلم بصراحة.
أحيانا تأتي الاستعارة من الحاضر،
من الواقع العراقي.
الحمد لله أنا الوحيد في هذا الكون
الذي استثمر العربة الخشبية
في مواضيعه
لأنها الوسيلة الوحيدة
لنقل الجثث والأشلاء
بعد الانفجارات،
ولنقل التراث المسروق أيضًا.
في هذا العمل أناقش
جدارية الذهاب إلى الحرب.
هي إحدى جداريات الفن الآشوري المتقدم
وسلم يقابل الحرب، سلم من المعرفة.
الكتاب خير وسيلة للرقية.
استعارة من الواقع: ترسانات من الكونكريت
وعراقي يصرخ تحول إلى عمود كهرباء،
وملك وفي الحقيقة هو ليس ملك.
أشلاء ملك بابلي مرمية على الرصيف.
أسد بابل، رمز المدينة التي ولدت فيها،
مع حقيبة متواضعة.
هذه الحقيبة هي حقيبتي الشخصية
ترافقني دائما في السفر.
امرأة مغيبة.
نحن الشعوب الحاصلة على جائزة نوبل
في تغييب المرأة.
(تصفيق)
لكن هذا الحنان العظيم
الذي وضع الله سبحانه وتعالى في المرأة
وضعته في ابتسامتها ونجحت في تطبيق
كل ما أردت إنجازه
وهي تنتمي إلى هذا الإرث العظيم.
عنوان هذا العمل "أول البوح":
يمثل رأس الثور معنى الذكورة
في الفكر السومري القديم
وأول البوح أننا صادرنا الذكورة للأسف.
عراقي لا يزال يعزف
أمام صرح مهم من صروح التاريخ
وهو ملوية سامراء،
وتمثل السكة العمر الذي ذهب.
شكرا جزيلا لكم يا إخوتي.
(تصفيق)